I used to drink coffee every
morning and I still love coffee,
but I prefer a new cocktail
and the ingredients are
black and green tape blended
coconut oil and butter
from grass fed cows.
My favorite teas are polarity,
which is an aged black tea from China
has some critical applications for fat
loss among other things.
Then that comes in these large bricks
that are typically uh, air dried.
You can also get embers,
but they're very,
very hard to find and green tea
from Japan. Could we say sentia,
K B U s C.
Sencha.
The way I'm going to make
this team because I have a
canister tea basket full of
the who error in green team.
I'm going to pour hot water
over that and it can really,
you can really beat the hell
out of it who Eric can tolerate.
Very high temperature especially.
Typically what I like to do with this
too is I will let this steep the first
steep for about 30 to 60 seconds.
If you ever want to decaffeinate
your t here's a, here's a tip.
You steep it really quickly and hot water.
I mean say 180 degrees or hotter,
I mean I'd let it,
let it cool off from boiling for a few
minutes and then pour out the first
Stephen, that'll get rid of 70 80% of
the caffeine from the leaves themselves.
So let that sit and then we're going to
do the same thing in another because I'm
actually gonna use this to drink the tea
and there are many different ways to do
this. This is one that's, that's
helpful for doing it on the road.
So I'm gonna let this steep
for about two minutes.
In the meantime I'm going to do is get
my butter and I'm going to put in a
tablespoon for me to intestinal comfort.
One tablespoon of coconut oil,
which is about 40 to 60% medium
chain triglyceride by weight.
That's why you putting it in there, MCTs,
and then you're going to let him out.
You watch it all.
You can stirred up
all that fatty deliciousness
coming to the top.
We'll take our second bit of tea.
Now
put an m.
And what I found through experimentation
is that you can certainly blend this
and I actually travel with a small
pocket size blender for that purpose,
but just as easily you can grab a couple
of mixing sticks or spinning and mixed
up and you're in good shape.
If you want to head on it like a Guinness.
Then she uses the blender
is delicious.
Hey guys, this is Tim Ferriss here.
I'm just having my tea and my,
what would you attempt if you knew you
could not fail mug and for all of the
episodes of the Tim Ferriss experiment,
go to four hour work week.com forward
slash TB that's fou are et Cetera,
et cetera.com forward slash TV where you
will find not only all 13 episodes of
the Tim Ferriss experiment that
you will find extended interviews,
really indepth tutorials,
two to three hour indepth dissections of
some of these experts in their skills.
Tons of stuff that we just couldn't put
into 21 or 22 minutes of television,
but for all of it behind the scenes stuff,
all sorts of cool things
with every type of variety.
Go to four hour workweek.com forward
slash TV and thank you for watching.